tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono qua vj e non ci siamo su su su un
gioco molto intelligente ma va beh siamo
su ma perché la gente muore cazzo siamo
su google che sarebbe una roba tipo
presente su motori dreams era quel gioco
anche quello molto intelligente è un
gioco di calcio davvero tante virgolette
nei quali bisogna fare gli efficienti ma
qual è la mia porta è riuscito a farmi
autogol nuovo tipo di esultanza
bisognava bisogna saltare come degli
eventi eca e cadere perfetto
io esulto così adesso in avanti è
bellissima questo ha fatto lo proviamo
costruire gambi sembrava che anche
questa è la partita più equilibrata che
abbia mai visto come quelli quante cazzo
di palle cir attenti merda dice
indipendente la porta
[Musica]
[ __ ] sono morti tutti cosa vai vai
vai vai vai tira fai qualcosa se ragazzi
attento che quello sta avanzando a caso
che cazzo fa che convinzione che sa è un
attimo che si stanno menando di brutto o
se stanno facendo d'amore una delle due
cose
io sono convinto che il creatore di su
motori soffra di qualche problema
psichico non lo so sono come i ragazzi
se si entra lurida e per farlo entrare
vuole entrare maledizione dei che sei
solo tu sei l'uomo partita se l'uomo
partita eccolo eccolo
no non ci credo invece sì al caso
che culo ho fatto un gol che non si è
capito nasce come va va va bene così
vinca il migliore lurido no no no no no
no no fermo si è caduto veloce veloce fa
qualcosa
ok bravo bravo eccola la vera finale dei
mondiali lega argentina germania è fatta
così no non una berlina più si no cazzo
c'era quasi da fermo ma l'arbitro tanto
non vede quindi posso calciati quanto
voglio toglie che togli tira la mia
dalla mia vista cosa fanno stanno
amoreggiando in campo sembrato tanto con
la si sta suicidando soddisfatti mi
diceva posso fare vai
si no che cosa fa quello veloce veloce
prima che si alzi la stiamo facendo noi
no perché visto che però continua a
cadere se riesco ad andare ragazzi a
porta vuota e difficile sbaglia bravo
eccolo eco veloce
no no sì sì sì sì
eccolo è il gol del sai cosa ti tocchi
tu cosa ti trovi cos'è stavo dio santo
come fai a calciare una palla così ma
che cazzo è la partita di calcio la
terza guerra mondiale una dei due
insieme a partita di rugby o cosa così
nel casino dai dai spingi quella palla
ma dice no non ancora che si stanno già
si guarda che se li ha portato al tavolo
che se la porta volta dai poi due passi
dio santo due passi
bravo così adesso fai una porca tua
sorella no no non mi svenire sul pallone
per forni fai un favore al milan ma se
ciò che hanno insieme o contro solo di
buttarla non chiede di cacciarla fuori
mio dio no no no no no no torna indietro
veloce però cazzo cazzo ragazzi di penso
maledizione sono tutti io sto difendendo
con un solo uomo anche abbastanza
deficiente quindi sono nella merda
[ __ ] va fantino tifa chiamati a
voi per fare squadra mio dio voglia di
spiegarmi questa ho visto ho vinto a
caso c'è una cosa è il primo che tocca
bild con le parole sto perdendo di
continuo fantasma affanculo maresca
neanche a partire
ma una 5 sto perdendo clamorosamente
piquadro ok adesso ci si che ci siamo
mai così bravo bravo no non inciampare
sott'olio da li togli lo togli lo perda
lo sapevo che quel corpo e voce veloce
si è entrato un pallone da volta opposta
non si sa come ma meglio così li
togliete per fortuna una sola di queste
palline minuscole deve entrare in porta
ce la facciamo la facciamo
no non in quella merda voglio di
calciare la palla non maltrattare la
porta lurido si calcio ama fare qualcosa
sono uscito
sono uscito dal dentro la porta bravo
bravo bravo bravissimo no mica se segna
così mi metto a ridere
cosa fai cosa fa ma mica quello fa la
gallina già dalla gallina dall'area
legale in fai qualcosa due passi
indietro ce la fai
sì sì che mi sembra di aver vinto il
mondiale con la rimasto impalato di
brutto ma ho vinto come si fa a segnare
così riescono anche a muovermi
fantastica è che si fa così è più mai
più fattibile anche mia parata ho fatto
alzato idiota no no lab e proprietaria
di no no ma perché è amico mio ma stai
cercando cosa pregavano capito se sta
facendo un tour king oppure se sta
cercando di infilarsi un palo nel
deretano ma sono teorie la casa che non
ho capito come mai non ti stai alzando
da mezz'ora che sei così e ai anche
preso una palla nel culo fantastico
ragazzi io non ho veramente pata sesto
gioco
pensavo fosse non senso non ora questi
livelli giuro magari che le segue no
[ __ ]
fatemi fare il giro nola spaccata con è
difficile make money e niente come voi
adesso si è preso con le spaccate
fantastico
[Musica]
no no no no no no che cazzo siete da
carissimi lega pro che non ci fosse mi
ha smontato la porta la porta tutta
amico mio sei assurdo in una maniera
incredibile ma non importa c'era niente
ma mi stai stuprando coselli in groppa
non si capisce se si sta schierando tipo
pressing non lo so 12 si è rivelato
ragazzo s'è liberato quindi niente mia
danti ha dato un bacino fantastico io
sono morto ragazzo rimasto con le da
mezz'ora in sono così quindi credo di
essere morto ragazzi questo è che questa
partita giusta ragazzi ho trovato il
team giusto credo eccolo di perfett
questa è la partita perfetta qualcuno o
qualcuna ha segnato ma so chi di preciso
ma qualcuno l'ha fatto partita in spazi
poi ho capito che c'è crisi e quindi
bisogna restringere i catrami oddio non
so se ho giocato mai a un qualcosa di
così strano credo che cazzo è successo
[Musica]
avevamo la gente a causa cioè io mio dio
qua c'è una palla a 300 persone un campo
striminzito voglio vedere come ci
arriviamo alla porta dicevo il bello è
che svengono nel momento che parta
partita vengono tutti c'è tipo prima
erano tutti in piedi poi vengono a caso
almeno allora no ma cos'era quello ma mi
fate due passaggi che siano due in croce
proprio sì sì bravo non ci si fa ci
credo ragazzi non ci credo forza piccolo
uomo forza forse se gli avversari mi
buttano la palla in mezzo ce la posso
fare
bravi dai dai dai cazzo che tira dentro
[Musica]
no non c'è cosa fai siamo in 14 1 la
butta dentro vero
[Musica]
basta perché non ce la posso più fare è
stata l'ultimo sforzo proprio non è
possibile cena cos'è questo cos'è si sta
robot io cosa fanno
ragazzi stanno ammazzando roma se non si
muove non ci parlò nicchia che figo alla
femmina teoria stanno venendo tutti
bellissimo lo so che voi 27 degli amanti
perfetti e che vi volete molto bene ma
basta fare sti atti osceni in luogo
pubblico carminativo che devo tipo mica
avevo quello di colpisco svengono cd po
come se la palla fosse una palla di
cannone a pasqua sono una persona
malvagia la prima d'ora yatzy quindi
direi che posso concludere qui visto che
la partita si sta facendo è quanto
strana quindi ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto come al solito so che un
commento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e bonanni video trovate la
descrizione 0 0 ieri cityscape ci
vediamo il prossimo video bella ragazza